[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas de nuestra región
relacionadas con la pandemia del hobbit
19 a continuación les presento los temas
que vamos a desarrollar en esta emisión
vamos a conocer detalles del pasaporte
sanitario propuesto en la unión europea
de ser aprobado como esto podría afectar
a los viajeros latinoamericanos en el
'viejo continente' como funcionará y qué
propósito tiene mientras avanza también
la vacunación en europa y también
algunos países regresan a los
confinamientos sobre todo en italia y en
francia hablaremos de chile que sigue
liderando la vacunación en américa
latina' este país suramericano ya superó
los cinco millones de personas
inoculadas una cifra en tiempo récord
pero el coi 19 no da tregua en ese país
suramericano ha superado ya la barrera
de los 6 mil casos de contagio en sólo
24 horas
por este motivo 24 comunas incluida
también santiago la capital van a
regresar a un confinamiento tenemos
todos los detalles y también destacado
para esta emisión es un hecho los
rápidos contagios en los últimos días la
saturación en los hospitales y la
cantidad de víctimas mortales
convirtieron a brasil en el epicentro de
la epidemia del hobbie 19 a nivel
mundial con más de 11 millones de casos
y más de 290.000 víctimas mortales
la comunidad internacional le pide al
gobierno brasileño que tome cartas en el
asunto para evitar una crisis que se
pueda extender a otros países de la
región en donde también están luchando
por hacer frente a la pandemia de 1.019
esto sucede mientras un nuevo ministro
de salud llega para intentar mitigar la
situación pues estos son algunos de los
temas vamos a comenzar entonces en
europa fue noticia destacada a lo largo
de esta semana la decisión de la
comisión europea que anunció que diseñó
un plan para poner en marcha un
certificado sanitario o pasaporte de
vacunación con el objetivo de frenar la
propagación del cobre el 19 esta idea
busca que el bloque europeo pueda
mantener sus fronteras abiertas y salvar
la temporada del verano boreal pero qué
va a pasar con los viajeros
latinoamericanos que restricción habrá
sobre todo porque algunas de las vacunas
como sputnik be y también la vacuna de
sinovac que son usadas en américa
latina' no están autorizadas para ese
pasaporte en europa veamos
a hacer que europa vuelva a moverse y
mantener sus fronteras abiertas de forma
segura así fue como la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen
presentó los puntos positivos del
llamado pasaporte vacunas o como se
conoce oficialmente el certificado verde
digital edge shows stage muestra o
indica si la persona ha sido vacunada o
una prueba negativa reciente o se ha
recuperado de kobe 19 y por lo tanto de
anticuerpos por fabricar versión pop y
tandas anti por y en segundo lugar este
certificado garantizará que los
resultados o lo que muestre los datos el
conjunto mínimo de datos se reconozcan
mutuamente en todos los estados miembros
entre ambas stage el pase en sí sería
distribuido por las autoridades
nacionales o los servicios de salud
contendría información personal básica
en inglés y en el idioma del país de
misión así como un código qr el
documento debería ser gratuito y la
unión europea debería brindar apoyo a
los estados miembros para desarrollar e
implementar esa tecnología
el paso digital ha sido aplaudido por
algunos como una forma de hacer que el
turismo vuelva a funcionar este verano
pero también ha planteado cuestiones
éticas y logísticas con respecto a la
protección de datos y la igualdad de
acceso a los viajes sin embargo la unión
europea se apresuró a recordar a los
europeos que su libertad fundamental de
movimiento entre los estados miembros no
estaba amenazada el pase digital
simplemente facilitaría los viajes
erradicando la necesidad de protocolos o
pruebas de cuarentena todas las vacunas
aprobadas por la agencia europea de
medicamentos estarían autorizadas para
el certificado de hecho la presidenta de
la comisión europea subrayó que con una
tercera ola de kobe de la mira la
vacunación generalizada es la mejor
estrategia vamos a conocer más detalles
de esta medida que impulsa la comisión
europea y que deberá ser aprobada pronto
por los gobiernos de los 27 países que
integran la unión europea estela herrera
en bruselas muy buenas noches
esther que piensan entonces los
ciudadanos comunitarios de ésta
que puede llegar a ser aprobada
se trata sin duda de una buena noticia
para los ciudadanos europeos que al
igual que una gran mayoría del resto del
mundo están recibiendo esta sensación de
fatiga pandémica así que este
certificado de alguna forma lo que
ofrece es un poquito de facilidad para
volver a viajar y dará un poquito
también esta sensación de que se puede
volver a la normalidad lo antes posible
con este certificado se podrá saber muy
claramente si una persona ha sido
vacunada bien tiene anticuerpos por
haber pasado la enfermedad o por otra
parte tiene un test negativo es cierto
que los países podrán seguir aplicando
cuarentena si así lo desean de hecho
tienen competencias para hacerlo pero
bruselas espera disuadir a los países
para que las sigan aplicando porque el
objetivo este certificado es que
básicamente sea mucho más fácil volver a
viajar por dentro de la unión europea
donde ahora mismo hay restricciones en
día en caso de algunos países bastante
duras con este certificado sobre todo lo
que se está permitiendo su moverse con
facilidad de nuevo por la
en europea recordemos que la libertad de
movimiento es una de las libertades más
importantes dentro de la unión europea
la de moverse por los países como si
fuera uno solo y sin importar las
fronteras la idea sobre todo tenerlo
preparado ya para junio para cuando
empiece la temporada de verano algo muy
importante para países turísticos como
españa o grecia que están deseando
recibir a nuevos viajeros este
certificado se podrá obtener tanto de
forma digital como en papel y lo podrán
obtener todos los ciudadanos europeos
pero también todos aquellos que residan
legalmente en cualquier país de la unión
europea sin importar su nacionalidad
esther de ser aprobado este pasaporte de
vacunación quedan excluidos los
ciudadanos que no son parte de la unión
europea eso indica que algunos países de
la periferia del bloque comunitario
quedan excluidos como van a ser el
manejo de la frontera y sobre todo con
aquellos países que tienen tratados como
por ejemplo el schengen pero no son
unión europea como noruega islandia y
suiza o liechtenstein como sería
entonces allí también incluiríamos en
este en este mismo paquete los
latinoamericanos que vienen de las
las extracomunitarias
si así es bueno la idea del certificado
sobre todo facilitar la movilidad dentro
de la unión europea por lo tanto ahora
mismo no se está pensando poderlo
ampliar a terceros países aún así no se
descarta que se puede hacer en el futuro
por ejemplo que algunos países tengan un
certificado parecido al europeo
entonces se puede llegar a acuerdos
bilaterales aunque bruselas cree que no
se va a poder llegar a tiempo para la
temporada de verano que empieza de aquí
a tres meses así que qué va a pasar con
los viajeros que provengan de fuera de
la unión europea pues van a seguirlo
obteniendo complicado las fronteras
exteriores de la unión europea siguen
prácticamente cerradas y aunque se puede
viajar todas las personas que quieran
entrar dentro de la unión europea están
sujetas a cuarentenas y test negativos
eso sí desde la comisión a los voy a
asegurar que el certificado tiene una
fecha de caducidad porque cuando la oms
declara el fin de la pandemia este
certificado ya no tendrá valor y ya no
será necesario está esta medida tiene el
foco en hacer un ensayo y error si esto
resulta exitoso puede ser copiado por
muchos países o por muchas regiones
américa latina pero la unión europea
está bajo mucha presión porque ya ha
sido muy señalada y muy criticada por el
manejo que le ha dado a la pandemia de
kobe 19 a la distribución de las vacunas
para hacer una reducción en el número de
casos ya vemos la situación que se está
presentando en francia en italia en este
momento donde vuelven los confinamientos
hay mucha presión en bruselas
pues siendo de la comisión europea ha
tomado muy en serio lo de esta propuesta
que se discutirá en la próxima reunión
de líderes europeos del 25 de marzo y
puede que no gane porque a bruselas le
llegaba la presión de los países que más
dependen del turismo grecia españa
también italia o portugal que estaban
insinuando en que si no tenían un
certificado digital ellos harían el suyo
propio por su cuenta o bien aplicarían
acuerdos bilaterales con países que ya
están llegando a vacunar a una gran
parte de la población como por ejemplo
israel pero dentro de los países habrá
muchas críticas y ya las hay de hecho
porque algunos consideran que este
certificado no tiene demasiado sentido
apenas hay un 12% aproximadamente de la
población de la unión europea que ahora
mismo está siendo vacunada por lo tanto
es cierto que si bien de aquí a junio ya
habrá una población mayor vacuna de
estos países creen que igual es un poco
prematuro hacer este certificado pero
aún así hay otras dudas también sobre
y las personas que están vacunadas no
llevan consigo el virus y pueden
transmitirlo a las personas que no estén
esta es una de las dudas que aún quedan
actualmente personas espera realmente en
todo caso que con este certificado se
acabe con la idea de que es
discriminatorio porque algunos países
sienten que algunas personas se pueden
sentir obligadas a vacunarse para poder
viajar pero es cierto que hasta que no
se alcance una inmunidad de rebaño las
personas que no quieran o que no puedan
aún vacunarse tendrán que estar
obligadas a cuarentenas oates en
negativos lo que sí podría tener cierta
discriminación y de hecho algunos países
como bélgica yang y yang se han mostrado
con dudas sobre esta cuestión así que la
batalla para poder aprobar este
certificado puede no ser nada fácil
están muchas gracias por explicarnos más
detalles de este pasaporte de vacunación
en europa que podría entrar en vigor y
que puede afectar a los viajeros
latinoamericanos de cierta forma muchas
gracias y américa latina también respiró
tranquila después de que la agencia
europea de medicamentos ema y la
organización mundial
salud avalaron el uso de la vacuna
desarrollada por la farmacéutica
astrazéneca el anuncio tiene lugar
después de que un gran número de países
en su mayoría europeos suspendieron su
utilización por efectos secundarios
aparentemente por estar relacionada con
la formación de coágulos de sangre en
las personas que ya habían sido
inmunizadas tras este anuncio las
autoridades de países como alemania
francia e italia informaron que
reanudarán la inoculación con esta
vacuna
espaldarazo a la vacuna de astrazéneca
países europeos como alemania francia e
italia reanudarán la vacunación este
mismo viernes con gran confianza lo
anunció el primer ministro francés yann
castex
en fax y ni me voy a inocular mañana por
la tarde con esta vacuna para mostrar
que la gente puede estar segura con agua
con jones antes la agencia europea de
medicamentos había calificado
astrazéneca como segura y eficaz pese a
las sospechas de causar trombos como
efectos secundarios
esta es una vacuna segura y eficaz sus
beneficios para proteger a las personas
del comil 19 con los riesgos asociados
de muerte y hospitalización superan los
posibles riesgos factores que cometió un
comité también concluyó que la vacuna no
está asociada con un aumento en los
riesgos generales de eventos
tromboembólicos o coágulos de sangre
antes al plato pge había expectación
tras días de evaluación por parte del
organismo de salud europeo y después de
que un grupo de países europeos y otros
en el mundo hubieran suspendido la
inoculación
sin embargo este mismo jueves la
organización mundial de la salud también
había aconsejado continuar con la vacuna
de astrazéneca fue en ese momento
debemos permanecer firmes en nuestra
aplicación de todas las vacunas
disponibles para responder al virus pero
la vacunación en el mundo con
astrazéneca no para este es el director
del servicio de salud británico y está
la presidenta de georgia tampoco fue
interrumpida la vacunación en bélgica
mientras que en brasilia se han
producido las primeras 500.000 dosis de
la vacuna en méxico recibirá dos
millones y medio de dosis de astrazéneca
procedentes de eeuu y chile líder en
vacunación en la región recibirá
próximamente ochocientos noventa mil
dosis de astrazéneca mediante el
programa kóvacs de la oms
vamos a conversar con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia y
asesor científico de france24 muy buenas
noches doctor como siempre un gusto
saludarlos y quiero conocer primero su
opinión sobre este tema que estábamos
conversando con la corresponsal en
bruselas la idea de ese pasaporte de
vacunación que puede entrar en vigencia
en europa puede ser una idea que se
pueda replicar aquí en américa latina' o
por lo menos en algunos países como lo
ve usted
y yo creo que esta es una forma de
hablar no solamente la vacunación que es
importante saberlo es tener una prueba
de pcr reciente que sea negativa tal vez
que sea una semana antes y también o
demostrar la presencia anticuerpos si la
persona se ha recuperado
no es solamente no es un pasaporte de
vacunación es un pasaporte que
contemplaría la inmunidad yo creo que es
una idea que hay que poner sobre la mesa
hay que discutirla tiene sus pros tiene
sus contras pero sin duda vamos a tener
que evaluar la inmuno de necesidad de
las vacunas y los anticuerpos para
facilitar el paso de las fronteras es la
hora de hacer también propuestas
disruptivas para lograr una normalidad
en poco tiempo
doctor pérez también quiero hablar con
usted con el otro tema por el otro tema
destacado de la semana y es ese mensaje
de la ema y de la oms a que la vacuna de
astrazéneca funciona sin ningún tipo de
problema que fue lo que sucedió entonces
con estos pacientes que presentaron
coágulos y usted nos puede dar un parte
de tranquilidad desde su conocimiento
sobre el uso de esta vacuna que usted ha
estudiado y usted sabe cómo está
desarrollada
santiago acá hay tres cosas importantes
la primera todas las vacunas son
medicamentos y no son inocuos es lo
primero son seguros pero no inocuos lo
segundo cuando se hace un estudio de lo
que se trata de mostrarles si hay una
causalidad es decir si la vacuna produjo
el daño y esto quedó totalmente
descartado lo tercero es porque
aparecieron estos pacientes recordemos
que actualmente se están vacunando
pacientes mayores de 80 años con varias
comorbilidades que han estado por
ejemplo inmovilizados y son otros
factores que pueden llevar al fenómeno
del embolismo y la fabricación de
trombos
que no necesariamente es la relación con
la vacuna sino un evento paralelo que
poder sucedido con presencia ausencia
vacuna lo que dice la emea la
organización mundial de la salud y la
reactivación de los países es que la
información que tienen no hay causalidad
es decir que la vacuna está escénica que
se ha aplicar en nuestra región pues va
a ser una una segura como están las que
se están vacunando en el momento en
varios países y esta va a ser
s de esa necesidad que tenemos de más
vacunas para inmunizar a más personas en
nuestra región doctor pérez aquí vuelve
a entrar en la ecuación entonces un
rumor o un estudio que hubo al principio
de la pandemia y es el uso de la
aspirina para evitar la coagulación
evitar la formación de trombos en la
sangre vuelve a entrar entonces en esta
ecuación que posiblemente pueda
incorporarse dentro de los tratamientos
para tratar el kobe o para las personas
que reciben la vacuna de astrazéneca los
días posteriores que tomen algunas dosis
de aspirina
no definitivamente no porque primero la
acción de la aspirina no es una acción
inmediata y además de eso consumir
aspirinas sin una indicación médica
también tiene riesgos como sangrado
digestivo por ejemplo alteración en la
coagulación de las plaquetas entonces el
paciente va a ser llevado a una cirugía
tiene un trauma puede tener problemas en
su coagulación por eso es que esta
aspirina de ser médica y la relación con
los trombos no tiene que ver con la
vacuna
eso ya está claro los pacientes con copd
ciertamente tiene un efecto pro
trombótico pero para eso se usan los
anticoagulantes en el momento que se la
persona está enferma pero no hay
tratamientos preventivos para eso es
decir que eso no solamente es un rumor
sino que puede producir dar un doctor
muchas gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa como siempre un gusto por
aclarar todas nuestras dudas en torno a
este tema de la pandemia de kobe 19
vamos a cambiar de tema el gobierno de
eeuu confirmó que este país está
dispuesto a enviar y a compartir un
cierto número de dosis de vacunas contra
el jove y 19 con méxico y con canadá que
son sus vecinos con los que tiene
extensas fronteras terrestres y con los
que tiene un alto flujo de intercambio
fronterizo la casa blanca indicó que de
esta manera busca ayudar a combatir el
coronavirus en esos países si bien la
estrategia aún no ha sido muy bien
definida por el gobierno este indicó que
está trabajando ya para ponerla en
marcha desde washington semanas atrás el
gobierno mexicano había presionado a la
casa blanca para que compartiera algunas
vacunas con ellos para poder aumentar y
agilizar la inmunización de todo el
territorio mexicano
y marío carbonell en ciudad de méxico
tiene más detalles y más información de
otros hechos de este y otros hechos
ocurridos allí en la republica mexicana
mario gracias por estar con nosotros en
el programa y ya lo decíamos fue
anunciado entonces esta intención de la
casa blanca de enviar algunas vacunas a
mexico y a canadá que dicen allí en
méxico sobre el tema que se sabe de esta
estrategia y sobre todo el tema
migratorio vuelve a quedar sobre la mesa
en esta negociación
así es tanto el canciller marcelo ebrard
como el presidente de lópez obrador
confirmaron el envío de eeuu a méxico de
2.700.000 dosis de la vacuna de
astrazéneca en calidad de préstamo el
presidente ha dicho que eso fue posible
gracias a las gestiones que él mismo
realizó durante una charla telefónica
que tuvo hace tiempo con el presidente
joe biden y que pues se da en el marco
de la colaboración que ha existido
siempre entre las dos naciones es en
préstamo porque una vez que méxico tenga
disponible ya la propia producción de
vacunas de astrazéneca estas dosis serán
devueltas se ha dicho que esto es una
especie de quid pro quo a cambio de un
mayor control migratorio para frenar la
oleada de indocumentados hacia eeuu las
autoridades de ambos países han dicho
que no tiene que ver una cosa con la
otra que no hay ninguna condicionante y
que son temas que se abordan de manera
paralela lo cierto es que méxico cerró
la frontera norte y sur al tránsito
terrestre no esencial a partir de este
viernes y hasta el próximo 21 de abril
es importante aclarar entonces que es un
préstamo entonces entendiendo cómo están
las cosas en méxico porque se están
pidiendo prestadas algunas dosis de
vacunas cómo está avanzando allí la
vacunación cómo está la llegada de las
dosis y los compromisos que ya había
adquirido méxico con las farmacéuticas y
con el sistema kóvacs
méxico adquirido 240 millones de dosis
de vacuna contra kobe 19 sin embargo
hasta la fecha solamente el país ha
recibido 8 millones de dosis son tres
millones de sinovac 3.9 millones de
facer 400.000 de la vacuna de sputnik y
870 mil de astrazéneca estas ya listas
para su aplicación provenientes del
instituto cero de la india porque hay
que decir que el contrato que se tiene
directamente con astrazéneca por 77
millones de dosis pues aún está en
camino se han recibido 12 millones de
dosis de sustancia activa las que son
aquí producidas y envasadas en mexico
pero que aún no están listas de estas 8
millones de vacunas se han aplicado ya
poco más de 5 millones a la población
mexicana principalmente a médicos y
adultos mayores van tres y medio
millones de adultos mayores que han
recibido ya al menos una primera dosis y
en cuanto a territorio se ha aplicado
vacunas en más de 1.000 municipios
de los poco más de 2000 que hay en el
país
el proceso de vacunación en méxico
tampoco escapa a las críticas ya los
señalamientos han detectado muchas
inconsistencias en los procesos de
aplicación en la logística en la
infraestructura que dicen allí
pues en el arranque de la aplicación
masiva de vacunas
pudieron ver pues varios obstáculos por
ejemplo en el estado de méxico aquí
vecino de la capital del país los
primeros días sobre todo pues fue un
poco caótico con largas filas muchas
horas de espera bajo el rayo del sol de
los adultos mayores para recibir sus
dosis porque había desorganización había
fallas de logística sin embargo hoy por
hoy ya hay un esquema mucho más adecuado
aquí en la ciudad de mexico se está
organizando por alcaldías hay 16
alcaldías y se están aplicando tandas de
vacunas de dos en dos demarcaciones o de
tres en tres con la lista del abecedario
es decir el apellido de cada persona
determina la fecha y la hora de su
aplicación de vacunas es así como ha
avanzado pues digamos un poco lento no
tan velozmente como quisiéramos pero las
autoridades dicen de manera segura esta
aplicación y se mantiene la promesa de
vacunar a todos los adultos mayores del
país antes del mes de abril
gracias mario por actualizar nos de todo
lo sucedido a lo largo de esta semana
allí en mexico en torno a la pandemia de
kobe 19 buen fin de semana a
continuación demos un vistazo al avance
de la vacunación en la región de
centroamérica cómo están las cifras para
el cierre de esta semana vamos a
comenzar de norte a sur comenzamos en
guatemala ya allí unas 55 mil 60 dosis
han sido aplicadas en belice 11 1943
mientras que en el salvador ya registran
42 mil 500 dosis inoculadas seguimos de
norte a sur vamos en esta gráfica hasta
honduras con 28 mil 570 dosis aplicadas
costa rica que es uno de los líderes de
esta región cierra la semana con 248 mil
82 dosis el istmo de panamá es quien
lleva la delantera en la inmunización en
centroamérica con 266 mil 298 dosis
aplicadas no mencionamos nicaragua
porque no hay cifras oficiales de este
país o al menos de una fuente que
podamos creer para poder presentarse las
a ustedes aquí en el programa vamos a
hablar ahora
chile en chile el gobierno de sebastián
piñera calificó como una victoria
colectiva el haber alcanzado un objetivo
de los 5 millones de personas vacunadas
contra el cob y 19 una cifra que
representa más del 80 por ciento de la
población en alto riesgo en ese país
suramericano la meta de chile sigue
siendo muy ambiciosa y es inocular a 15
de los 19 millones de habitantes del
país antes de la mitad de este año de
acuerdo con la ope s unas 28 millones de
dosis de vacunas ya han sido
suministradas en américa latina' un poco
más de 28 millones a lo largo de esta
semana
a la cabeza de la vacunación en américa
latina chile logró vacunar 5 millones de
personas contra el coi 19 en 41 días dos
semanas antes de la fecha prevista por
el gobierno para inocular su población
el presidente sebastián piñera reconoció
el logro como el resultado de un trabajo
conjunto tenemos más de 5 millones de
chilenas y chilenos vacunados local ha
sido sin duda un trabajo
y difícil y que ha significado la
contribución de cientos de miles de
personas chile anunció su campaña de
vacunación el pasado 3 de febrero y
ahora a comienzos de esta semana el
ministerio de salud anunció que ya se
había vacunado al 85% de la población
mayor de 60 años el siguiente objetivo
del gobierno es comenzar a inocular el
próximo 24 de marzo a la población entre
50 y 59 años de edad para esto el
ministro de relaciones exteriores
rodrigo yáñez dijo que continuará los
diálogos con laboratorios
internacionales hemos seguido
conversaciones con otros laboratorios
pensando en enfrentar lo que va a ser el
segundo trimestre
que va a ser muy importante para
terminar este ciclo de vacunación de la
población objetivo que es el 80 por
ciento de la población y 15 por 15
millones de personas si bien esta es una
noticia alentadora el país suramericano
debe esperar para cantar victoria con un
repunte de 5.000 nuevos casos de
contagio al día y el 65% de ocupación de
las 3.200 camas de uso disponibles es
pronto para que los 5 millones de
vacunas influyan en los marcadores
epidemiológicos del territorio
y hablamos ahora de ecuador allí
renuncio el cuarto ministro de salud de
la administración del presidente de
lenin moreno y el tercero desde el
inicio de la pandemia del cob y 19 en
ese país
rodolfo farfán deja la cartera en medio
de señalamientos por las irregularidades
en la vacunación a algunas figuras
reconocidas de la actualidad ecuatoriana
previamente gustavo ortega desde quitó
nos dio más detalles de esta noticia
adelante gustavo
18 días duró en el cargo del cuarto
ministro de salud de ecuador
rodolfo farfán renunció a menos de 80
días que concluya el gobierno de lenin
moreno az irregularidades en el plan de
vacunación no cesaron con el cambio el
ministro juan carlos ceballos quiero yo
del país con una causa abierta de
investigaciones por las listas secretas
en la fase cero de inoculación
el escándalo se destapa cuando concluye
el tiempo de una orden judicial que
obligaba el actual ministro de salud
hacer públicas las listas secretas que
no se conocieron y concluyó con la
renuncia irrevocable argumentando
razones personales
paralelamente se conoció una publicación
del vídeo digital en la posta de los
nombres que incluyen la primera dama
rocío moreno colaboradores del
presidente de la república el ministro
de defensa abogados conocidos rectores
universitarios y el coordinador de
campaña del candidato presidencial
guillermo lasso
entre otros la publicación de los
nombres cercanos del presidente
obligaron al ejecutivo nacional a
justificar la vacunación como un asunto
de seguridad nacional ante la condición
vulnerable y física de lenin moreno la
defensoría del pueblo reclaman la
transparencia de la vacunación cuando
apenas ha llegado al país 1,5 por ciento
de las 20 millones de dosis negociadas
luego de negarlo y esquiva
las presiones en contra del gobierno
continúan destapando el tema que se
mantiene en secreto gracias gustavo en
quito la capital ecuatoriana y esta
semana brasil se mantuvo entre las
noticias destacadas de la región este
país superó por primera vez las 2800
muertes por kobe y 19 en un período de
24 horas una cifra que sumada a la
saturación sanitaria y la cantidad de
nuevos casos lo han convertido en el
epicentro de la pandemia a nivel mundial
una situación que preocupa también a la
región en suramérica porque con
dificultad han hecho frente a la crisis
sanitaria que dio paso también a una
crisis institucional con la renuncia
nuevamente del ministro de salud también
en brasilia lo veíamos en ecuador el
nuevo encargado de esa cartera en brasil
marcelo quiroga asume en el peor momento
de la pandemia veamos
el ejecutivo brasileño redobla esfuerzos
para aumentar la vacunación en el país
lo hace mientras el gobierno da un golpe
de timón a su política contra la
pandemia y mientras la emergencia se
agudiza día tras día en la nación con
estos cuatro actos
estamos pidiendo 100 millones de dosis
de facer según lo programado admisión en
abril 25 millones en mayo 10 millones en
junio 10 millones en julio 30 millones
en agosto y 46 millones en septiembre 46
el número total de vacunas contratadas
por el ministerio de salud son 562
millones de dosis para el año 2021
a pesar de ser uno de los países más
afectados la vacunación en brasil
comenzó apenas a mediados de enero y ha
avanzado lentamente en medio de una
feroz tercera ola de casos el presidente
de jair bolsonaro cambió su retórica
sobre la vacunación y admitió que es
fundamental para superar la pandemia en
los últimos días el mandatario también
comenzó a utilizar mascarilla y anunció
que reemplazará al muy desprestigiado
salud eduardo para suelo el tercero
durante su mandato presidente de satena
sátrapas y el presidente busca
reorganizar el ministerio
y 4 y eso no fue hasta que eso sea
definitivo la vida continúa de manera
habitual no estoy enfermo no he pedido
irme yo no pido cifras allí se prevé que
su reemplazo el cardiólogo marcelo
quiroga pase al mando de la cartera en
los próximos días lo hace en un momento
crítico el país epicentro de la pandemia
en la región y de nuevas variantes del
virus ha superado por primera vez las 2
mil 800 muertes diarias por kobe 19 y
suma más de 281 mil decesos y 11,6
millones de contagios
y también el vecino uruguay comienza a
ver el lado más complicado de la
pandemia de kobe 19 este país que por
meses fue uno de los ejemplos a seguir
por su gestión ahora está rompiendo
récords de contagio en algunos días de
la semana superó los 1.600 mientras
tanto la vacunación rezagada comparado
con el resto de la región pues uruguay
fue uno de los países de los últimos
países de la región en poner en marcha
un plan de inmunización veamos entonces
cómo está el panorama hikari nadal más
desde la ciudad de punta del este
y karina uruguay como ya lo decíamos ha
comenzado a tener récords diarios de
contagio de kobe 19 como pasaron de ser
uno de los países más admirados por su
manejo de la pandemia a tener un
escenario muy preocupante según los
especialistas y la comunidad
internacional
efectivamente santiago uruguay pasó de
ser la excepción a ser el país con la
tasa más alta de nuevos casos en toda
latinoamérica incluso superando a brasil
sin embargo la tasa de letalidad del
porcentaje de vitalidad sigue siendo muy
bajo del 1 por ciento científicos
analizan la situación de uruguay e
indican que la 1° ola que se registró a
partir de diciembre del año pasado nunca
se pudo aplacar lo que se estaba viendo
ahora no es una segunda ola sino un
rebrote de la misma que la situación
continúa empeorando incluso alertan de
que en algunas zonas del país se está al
borde del desabastecimiento a nivel
sanitario
karina algunos especialistas critican
este modelo de éxito que tuvo uruguay
que consistía en cierre de las fronteras
no hubo confinamiento pero sí hubo mucho
cuidado ciudadano se puede decir que
están siendo de pronto víctimas de su
propio éxito
la libertad de responsable de la que
hacía la ilusión desde que inició la
pandemia el presidente luis lacalle pou
sin embargo en febrero el grupo de
asesores científicos honorarios que
brinda opinión al gobierno le solicitó
que hicieran medidas más estrictas en
cuanto a la movilidad por ejemplo el
cierre de negocios que no fueran
esenciales como podrían ser los
restaurantes y también que se generara
más trabajo remoto esto no ocurrió al
terminar las vacaciones de verano muchas
personas volvieron a sus puestos de
trabajo no todas las empresas hicieron
énfasis en el trabajo remoto luego
también el gobierno implementó el
retorno a la educación a las clases de
forma obligatoria y presencial esta
medida se cambió ahora volvió a ser
voluntaria hace apenas unos días algunos
científicos dicen que
de todos modos aunque se está iniciando
la vacunación esta no será suficiente
para parar esta ola de contagios
karina muchas gracias por este reporte
desde punta del este en uruguay así
llegamos al final de nuestro programa
nuestro resumen semanal en kobe 19 la
semana en américa nos volvemos a
encontrar la próxima semana mientras
tanto siguen se cuidando del cobi 19 y
sigan viendo france24
[Música]